are you a fan of the fable series well
if you were waiting for fable legends
I've got some unfortunate news Microsoft
has canceled Lionhead Studios latest
game on top of that the studio itself
may be shuttered soon press PLAY Studios
the developer of Mac's curse of the
Brotherhood is also closing its doors
xbox Europe's hanno Lemke said these
have been tough decisions and we have
not made them lightly nor are they a
reflection on these development teams we
are incredibly fortunate to have the
talent creativity and commitment of the
people at these Studios these changes
are taking effect as Microsoft Studios
continues to focus its investment and
development on the games and franchises
that fans find most exciting and want to
play press PLAY Studios is shutting down
but the status of lion head is still up
in the air due to the UK's mandatory
30-day consultation period it's always
sad to see studios close but considering
the portfolio of these two developers we
have confidence that everyone will land
on their feet to stay up to date on the
situation keep it locked to gamespot